I have a young daughter whom I want to
admit into an Islamic school. The
Islamic school is very far from my home.
We have a convent school right beside
our home. My wife argues that we put her
in the convent school as it is close to
our home. She cites reasons such as it
is unsafe to send a girl child far
nowadays. But I want to put her in an
Islamic school so that she can stay away
from shik have an Islamic environment
and at the same time gain worldly
progress. I do not mind risking her
sending far away. I faith in Allah
subhana wa t'ala that he will protect
her if I strive in his way. How do I
convince my wife?
But the um has asked a very good
question that he wants to send his young
child, the young daughter to an Islamic
school. But the wife is insisting that
since the Islamic school is very far,
better put in a school which is close by
even though it's convenient because it's
not safe to put the child in a school
which is far away. Basically, let me
tell you that Bangalore is a safe city.
Bangalore is not like Manhattan of New
York or Bronze.
city going to Bangalore many times I
have many friends so if your child is
going to school she's going to your
daytime so I don't think so it is unsafe
to send your child your daughter to a
school which is far away it may be half
an hour it may be 1 hour see to that you
arrange a proper transportation whether
it be a school bus whether it be a
proper vehicle which is secure I don't
think so it is
risky but what has to realize is that I
do agree with Omar the husband because
he is striving for the imagine if you're
putting your daughter in a convenient
school and she starts believing that
Jesus is God or she starts worshiping
Jesus peace be upon him will you be able
to forgive
yourself many times people give the
school that the school is father maybe
they are more impressed by the standard
of the school as compared to Islamic
schools but I'm aware that alhamdulillah
In Bangalore there are many Islamic
schools. You have a lot of options. You
can surely choose the school you feel
has a better standard which is more
close to Quran and Sunnah. And even if
hypothetically if the standard is less
than the con school which is close to
your house, it is preferable and safer
to put your child whether a daughter or
a son in Islamic school rather than a
commun school because there are high
chances that your child may go away far
from the gym. So I do agree with Omar
and I completely support him and I would
like to remind the sister that please
don't be so much relaxed and not at all
worried about putting your child in a
common school. There are high dangers
that they may go far away from the dean.
It is more dangerous than the danger of
thinking that's unsafe for a girl to
travel because if she goes far away from
the dean that is multiple times more
dangerous, more harmful, more unislamic
than talking about the safety of a child
and Allah is there to protect you and I
do agree with the statement of that if
you striving in the way of Allah
subhanana wa ta'ala surely Allah will
protect and Bangalore is a safe city.
How many cases have you heard that young
girls going in Bangalore to schools
which are far they have got problem hard
any cases and even if it's far and if
it's tiring Allah will support you
you'll get a better a and one more thing
it's good for you also because the
beloved prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam said that when a person dies
only three things continue asaria one is
the wealth that you spend in his way one
is the knowledge that you spread
about him about the dean and the third
is pious children praying for you. So if
your child is pious and prays for you
you will benefit. If your child is not
pious then it will get no benefit for
you in the aar. So it will not only
benefit the child it will benefit you
also if you put in a good authentic
Islamic school. Hope that answers the
question.